like look at the dollar system not to
pivot this into the dollar right away
but
the dollar that's like shaky ground who
truly understands the dollar system i
mean
the totality of it the euro dollar
system
the way that monetary policy interacts
with the economy
is monetary issuance inflationary
what's the relationship between
unemployment and inflation
even policy makers don't understand
these things economists don't seem to
understand them
what is deflation how do you define
inflation none of these things are
really known
or knowable so a lot of people kind of
make a claim that there's a lot of
manipulation possible with the dollar
with the
with those currencies if you couple that
with
the fact that people don't understand it
and yet
there's claims that being manipulated by
centralized power
how do you bring those two ideas
together
if no one understands it how can you
manipulate it i think what we don't
understand are the long-term
consequences
of our structures so like the feds
mandate
to target unemployment and steady
um you know exchange rates or low
inflation
you know what we don't understand is
okay what is the result of doing that
continuously for 40 years
right what is the net effect of that
what is the consequence of the long-term
accumulation of debt
and you know basement interest rates
what is the net effect of that on
society
we might understand just much short
short term
features of the system but i think it's
the longer term
features we don't understand do you
think there's like malevolent people
with people that don't have good intent
in central banks like
in the system you know
when you have centralized power in any
forms
it's susceptible to somebody hacking the
system
taking the power and in the shadows this
is where conspiracy theories come in
right in the shadows be able to
you know i've act out
things that have a lot of negative
impacts on a large percent of the
population
in self and greedy self-interest do you
think there's people like that or do you
think fundamentally most people are good
even those associated with the
sort of central banking oh i mean i
don't villainize those people
i think everyone is the hero of their
own story right so
they all believe that they're forced for
good in the world you have to are there
any true villains i don't think so i
think
they get socialized into a world where
they believe
their particular skills and their
mandate is
you know what they should be doing um i
think they might be
presumptuous or arrogant in some cases
um and you know i think it's more of a
systemic issue where you have
a small handful of very homogenous
types of people with phds from the same
institutions that are brought up in the
same cultural context
that you know set policy and wield a
tremendous amount of control over
society
and i think they have this notion that
you can tinker
society you can play with a few key
variables and tinker society into
a state that is desirable or good and
that's what they're trying to do
and i think the consequences of that can
be pretty bad
but no i don't think it's born out of
malevolence
you